OK, hopefully, my
tool is working now.
But anyway, so we were saying
when x is equal to minus 0.001,
so we're getting closer and
closer to 0 from the negative
side, f of x is equal
to minus 1,000, right?
You can just evaluate
it yourself, right?
And as you see, as x approaches
0 from the negative direction,
we get larger and larger-- or I
guess you could say smaller and
smaller negative
numbers, right?
You get-- you know, if it's
minus 0.0001, you'd get minus
10,000, and then minus 100,000,
and then minus 1 million, you
could imagine the closer and
closer you get to zero.
Similarly, when you go from the
other direction, when you say
what is-- when x is 0.01, there
you get positive 100, right?
When x is point-- the thing is
frozen again-- when it's 0.001,
you get positive 1,000.
So as you see, as you approach
0 from the negative direction,
you get larger and larger
negative values, or I guess
smaller and smaller
negative values.
And as you go from the positive
direction, you get larger
and larger values.
Let me graph this just to give
you a sense of what this graph
looks like because this is
actually a good graph to know
what it looks like
just generally.
So let's say I have the x-axis.
This is the y-axis.
Change my color.
So when x is a negative number,
as x gets really, really,
really negative, as x is like
negative infinity, this
is approaching zero, but
it's still going to be a
slightly negative number.
And then as we see from what we
drew, as we approach x is equal
to 0, we asymptote, and we
approach negative
infinity, right?
And similarly, from positive
numbers, if you go out to
the right really far, it
approaches 0, but it's
still going to be positive.
And as we gets closer and
closer to 0, it spikes up, and
it goes to positive infinity.
You never quite get
x is equal to 0.
So in this situation, you
actually have as x approaches--
so let me give you a different
notation, which you'll
probably see eventually.
I might actually do a separate
presentation on this.
The limit as x approaches 0
from the positive direction,
that's this notation
here, of 1/x, right?
So this is as x approaches 0
from the positive direction,
from the right-hand side, well,
this is equal to infinity.
And then the limit as x-- this
pen, this pen-- the limit as x
approaches 0 from the
negative side of 1/x.
This notation just says
the limit as I approach
from the negative side.
So as I approach x equal 0 from
this direction, right, from
this direction, what happens?
Well, that is equal
to minus infinity.
So since I'm approaching
a different value when I
approach from one side
or the other, this limit
is actually undefined.
I mean, we could say that from
the positive side, it's
positive infinity, or from the
negative side, it's negative
infinity, but they have to
equal the same thing for
this limit to be defined.
So this is equal to undefined.
So let's do another problem,
and I think this should
be interesting now.
So let's say, just keeping that
last problem we had in mind,
what's the limit as x
approaches 0 of 1/x squared?
So in this situation,
I'll draw the graph.
That's my x-axis.
That's my y-axis.
So here, no matter what value
we put into x, we get a
positive value, right?
Because you're going
to square it.
If you put minus-- you could
actually-- oh, let me do it.
It'll be instructive, I think.
Once again, obviously you
can't just put x equal to 0.
You'll get 1/0,
which is undefined.
But let's say 1 over x squared.
What does 1 over x
squared evaluate to?
So when x is 0.1, 0.1 squared
is 0.01, so 1/x is 100.
Similarly, if I do minus 0.1,
minus 0.1 squared is positive
0.01, so then 1 over that
is still 100, right?
So regardless of whether we put
a negative or positive number
here, we get a positive value.
And similarly, if I put-- if we
say x is 0.01, if you evaluate
it, you'll get 10,000, and if
we put minus 0.01, you'll get
positive 10,000 as well, right?
Because we square it.
So in this graph, if you were
to draw it, and if you have a
graphing calculator, you
should experiment, it
looks something like this.
I can see this dark blue.
So from the negative side, it
approaches infinity, right?
You can see that.
As we get to smaller and
smaller-- as we get closer and
closer to 0 from the negative
side, it approaches infinity.
As we go from the positive
side-- these are actually
symmetric, although I didn't
draw it that symmetric-- it
also approaches infinity.
So this is a case in which
the limit-- oh, that's
not too bright.
I don't know if you can see --
the limit as x approaches 0
from the negative side of 1
over x squared is equal to
infinity, and the limit as x
approaches 0 from the positive
side of 1 over x squared is
also equal to infinity.
So when you go from the
left-hand side, it
equals infinity, right?
It goes to infinity
as you approach 0.
And as you go from the
right-hand side, it
also goes to infinity.
And so the limit in general
is equal to infinity.
And this is why I got excited
when I first started
learning limits.
Because for the first time,
infinity is a legitimate answer
to your problem, which, I don't
know, on some metaphysical
level got me kind of excited.
But anyway, I will do more
problems in the next
presentation because you can
never do enough limit problems.
And in a couple of
presentations, I actually give
you the formal, kind of
rigorous mathematical
definition of the limits.